nach einer langen manchen würde sagen
elend lang suche hat die spd endlich
zwar neue parteivorsitzende
das ksk an norbert walter borjans sind
am freitag mit guten im falle von walter
borjans sogar sehr guten ergebnissen von
den delegierten des berliner parteitag
gewählt worden
die entscheidende frage aber ist ja nun
bringt das ruhe in die partei und wird
die spd in zukunft wieder erfolgreich
zahlen in umfragen und auch in war daran
kann man einigen zweifel haben
denn zwar bringt das wahlergebnis essen
und walter borjans einiges
innerparteiliche stellen dinge doch ist
die ruhe die jetzt herbeigeführt wurde
eine oberflächliche ruhe denn weiterhin
haben sich aspen und walter borjans sehr
kritisch zur großen koalition geäußert
gleichzeitig wollen sie aber in
verhandlungen treten mit der union vor
allen dingen über die schwarze null
wollen sie rede und auch über das klima
paket
es ist also unklar wer sich im endeffekt
durchsetzen wird wenn diese
verhandlungen abgeschlossen sind die
coco kritiker die immer noch eine große
gruppe stellen oder die befürworter der
großen koalitionen das signal dieses
parteitags ist also eher ein verhaltenes
weiter so und wir schauen mal und wir
verhandeln noch einmal nach auf jeden
fall keine revolution